all right welcome back everybody okay so
today we're gonna continue talking about
vector calculus so this is like
divergence gradient curl today what I
really want to talk about our integral
theorems so we're gonna talk about
Gauss's divergence theorem today and so
it's kind of a neat a extremely neat
theorem Gauss's theorem but it's also
the basis for a lot of the partial
differential equations that we're going
to see in the following quarter okay so
something kind of interesting that we'll
get to you today is that a lot of PDEs
can actually be derived through
conservation laws and conservation laws
usually mean I do some accounting over a
volume meaning I integrate some quantity
over a volume and I see how much it
changes and how much of that quantity
leaves the volume okay and using this
kind of integral approach to
conservation laws is how we usually
derive lots and lots of partial
differential equations okay there is a
chance this will be a bit of a short
lecture but we'll see okay okay so just
the topics overview of topics so first
we're going to talk just very briefly
about double and triple integrals that
triple doesn't have two peas okay then
we're going to talk about Gauss's
divergence theorem
I'll give you an example that's pretty
close to the example I gave on the
qualifying exam this last week so
actually I think that the example on
your homework set is the problem from
the qualifying exams wasn't that
creative this week and then we're going
to talk about how Gauss's theorem can be
used for mass conservation so the
continuity equation okay before I start
are there any questions about anything
in the class so far the last few weeks
the next few weeks
finals differential equations anything
okay so I mean it kind of feels like the
class is winding down because this is
the last week and then well this isn't
the last week this is I'll give three
lectures this week then I'll be gone all
of next week and then we'll have three
more final lectures in December and so
these next two weeks are really kind of
a catch-all for things that you
certainly should know for the next part
PDEs
but most of you probably already do now
okay so I'm assuming that most of you
have seen Gauss's theorem and know how
to do double and triple integrals and in
fact with double and triple integrals
I'm going to do one example today of a
volumetric integral but I'm going to
assume that you actually know how to do
you know compute areas and volumes and
things so if you need to do a little bit
of review then chapter 9 and krycek is
actually pretty good and there's a
number of ways that you can get access
to this book one Risa has desk copies in
her office
so I'm gonna really gloss over double
and triple integrals really quickly and
I'm gonna get to the interesting things
that you can do with these double and
triple integrals okay so really I'm
going to start with Gauss's theorem
okay so just a quick show of hands how
many of you have seen Gauss's theorem
before how many have nots okay how many
of you could use Gauss's theorem to
compute an integral right now probably a
few of you have started the homework
okay good
okay so Gauss's divergence theorem is
probably my favorite theorem in vector
calculus it's not everyone's favorite
theorem I know some people are partial
to Stokes theorem but I think this is a
really really good one so I'm gonna say
it in words first and then I'm gonna say
it in math okay so in words Gauss's
divergence theorem has to do with the
flux of quantities through a volume okay
or through a surface so the flux of a
vector field out of a closed surface
okay so I'm going to do it in words then
in math and then a picture so the flux
of a vector field out of a closed
surface is equal to the integral of the
divergence of the vector field over the
whole volume
okay I'm gonna draw a picture and then
I'm gonna write this in math okay so
let's say that I have some volume and I
have some vector field that's going on
in the background like I have my
velocity field or something like that so
the way I always think about this is
that I have some vector field like a
fluid and I have some volume of fluid
that I'm going to be studying okay maybe
this is a small teeny tiny little packet
of fluid and my coffee cup when I drop
cream in maybe this is five square mile
swath of oil in the Gulf of Mexico maybe
this is the entire trace of the
Fukushima radiation plume in the Pacific
anyway this is a volume in a vector
field okay so we have space we have some
vector field in space and I'm going to
study some volume in space okay so let's
call this volume V and we're gonna call
the surface of the volume so the surface
of this volume that I've carved out in
space we're gonna use this symbol
partial V and this is a commonly
accepted kind of mathematical language
partial V means the boundary of my
volume the surface enclosing my volume
okay this actually has good reason to
use the partial like partial derivative
because of the way that Stokes theorem
works we'll see that later and then
finally we're going to have some normal
vector pointing out of the surface okay
so what I want to know is how much stuff
is this vector field taking out of my
volume or carrying into my volume
that's what flux means super simple
concept
the flux of my vector field just means
how much stuff is being carried in or
out of my volume okay is this volume
accumulating mass is it losing mass or
is the math basically staying the same
okay and we can write this in math in
the following way okay so the first
quantity that we're interested in is
this flux of my vector field out of a
closed surface so that's equal to a
double integral on the boundary of my
volume of my vector field dotted in the
normal direction okay so if I was going
to keep track let's say I built a fence
around Seattle and I wanted to keep
track of who came in and who came out
all I would have to do is count how many
people go out and how many people come
in right so that means I'm gonna
integrate around the surface of my
volume the boundary of my volume and I'm
gonna figure out how much of my vector
field points out and I'm going to add up
all of that outward or inward
contribution okay and this is a fine
integral but it's kind of a pain to
represent this surface and find some way
to parameterize and it might be really
really hard to integrate some vector
field over a really nasty ill-defined
surface and what Gauss's theorem says is
that instead we can do this triple
volume integral over the entire volume
of the divergence of F over the whole
volume now this might not look like we
actually made anything easier because we
went from a double integral to a triple
integral usually that's a bad thing but
oftentimes when you take the divergence
of F this vector field divergence is
much much simpler than F itself okay so
for incompressible fluid flows this is
zero everywhere in all of space okay so
are there questions about what this kind
of me
physically or geometrically how many of
you would like me to say kind of what
this means physically one more time yeah
okay okay so just one more time this is
a super important theorem the idea is
oftentimes I'm interested in whether or
not of quantity is conserved like is
mass being conserved in this volume or
where will L go if it spills right we
know that the volume of oil is going to
be conserved and so sometimes I will
create this control volume and I'll want
to keep good accounting of how much
stuff is in this control volume how much
oil is in there how much nuclear waste
whatever and to do that I need to know
how much of that stuff is coming in and
how much of that stuff is going out all
right I want to know like the rate of
change of the quantities in this volume
and so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to take my vector field and if my vector
field is perfectly tangent to my surface
then that that part of the vector field
is not driving particles in or out but
if my vector field is pointing partially
outward then when I take the dot product
of F with my normal vector some portion
of that vector field is carrying
particles out or taking particles into
this volume so this integral here this
integral of my vector field dotted with
the normal integrated up over my entire
boundary is the flux integral or flux of
mass through partial V okay and Gauss's
theorem says that this always equals the
volume integral of the divergence of F
there are some really really cool proofs
for this and part of me really wants to
show you why this is true but a bigger
part of me thinks that you've probably
seen it before and it's probably not
going to make a huge difference but if
you are interested there's some great
great reasons why this is true
kind of intuitively and geometrically
you can get a sense for for why this
this divergence theorem is true okay so
let's do a really really simple example
and this is an example that's almost
exactly like the problem on your
homework and on the qualifying exam okay
so what we're going to do is our example
is we're going to take a sphere in XY
and Z ok so we're gonna take the sphere
and we're going to integrate the flux of
a certain vector field out of this
sphere okay so we're gonna let our
vector field F equal to X I plus y
squared J plus Z squared okay okay this
doesn't have any physical meaning I just
made up a vector field that had some
nice properties and so this vector field
F gives me a direction at every point XY
and Z right it's a vector field kind of
like in our Odie's and what we want to
know is how much of that vector field is
carrying mass out of the sphere vs into
the sphere what is the net flux of
things in or out of the sphere okay and
we're gonna say that this sphere is
given by the set of points XY and Z such
that x squared plus y squared plus Z
squared equals 1 ok ok so on the cols
you might have a problem like this you
might have a sphere and some vector
field and you're supposed to compute the
flux of that vector field through the
volume of the sphere
okay so compute
flux through s okay this is a great
classic divergence theorem problem
because if I wanted to integrate this F
across the surface I certainly could I
could say that's the integral of s of F
dots
my normal vector D s that's the flux
through my sphere of this vector field
but this is gonna be super nasty right
like F is this nasty function I'm gonna
have to find out what my normal vector
is dotted and do this weird integral
over this surface which is not easily
parametrized by X&Y okay so it's kind of
a pain to do this integral but Gauss's
divergence theorem makes this really
really easy so this is equal to the
integral of my volume of the divergence
of F so how do i compute the divergence
of F what is the divergence of F here
right I take all of the partials partial
this partial X plus partial this partial
y plus partial this partial Z okay
and I get div F equals 2 plus 2y plus 2z
right ok so at any point XY & z at any
point the flow is diverging or
converging in this amount and we can
take this vector field and we could
create a mesh grid of particles in
MATLAB and we could actually plot all of
those vectors for a mesh grid and see
that some places they're expanding some
places they're converging ok
okay so we have to compute this volume
of this quantity so we're computing the
integral volume integral of 2 + 2 y + 2
Z DV and there's something really cool
we can do here I'm gonna split this into
three integrals right integration is
also a linear operator so integral of a
plus B plus C is the same as integral of
A plus integral of B plus integral of C
so this equals I'm gonna drop the triple
integral because I'm sick of writing it
integral volume of two DV plus integral
volume of two y DV plus integral volume
of two Z DV okay the first term pretty
simple what is the volume of a sphere
4/3 PI R cubed R is 1 so it's just 4/3
pi so this equals 8 thirds pi that term
okay what about my other two terms if I
want to integrate Y over the volume of a
sphere what do I get so I'm going to go
through every single point in this
sphere and I'm going to add up Y and I'm
gonna get what
okay I heard one and six any other zero
sounds good why would you say zero
because it's symmetric there is as much
positive Y in the upper hemisphere as
there is negative Y in the lower
hemisphere okay so for every point that
I add up sorry I'm up or Z so for every
point positive Z there's a point
negative Z and those add up to 0 so my
integral of Z over the volume is 0 and
similarly my integral of Y is symmetric
and an equals 0 so that makes sense to
everyone why this integral has to be 0
so there's as much positive Y as
negative Y's as a symmetric surface as a
general rule on qualifying exams I will
almost certainly never give you an
integral that doesn't have some kind of
a symmetry because I hate doing nasty
integrals so these are both zero and
this is my answer
ok so this is an ax classic example of a
problem that is easy to do using Gauss's
divergence theorem I took this nasty
vector field integrated over some
surface that's hard to parameterize but
it turns out that the divergence of this
vector field is easy to integrate over
the volume okay so this is the amount of
flux through that sphere you could
imagine that these vector fields came
about through some physics problem right
I wrote down some maybe I have some
distribution of charges inside of the
sphere that are creating that vector
field or I have some kind of
gravitational potentials that's creating
this vector field so in reality these FS
that we're going to be integrating are
going to be physical vector fields like
gravitational potentials or Coulomb
charge distribution electrostatic
potentials and things like that
okay any questions about the kind of
mechanics of what we did here with the
integral so you can verify at home that
this surface integral is way way harder
than this volume integral just like try
to do it and it's kind of a pain okay
okay
so I will do one more example that is
even closer to the qualifying exam so I
figure no one would mind hearing how to
solve a homework problem right how many
of you have started this this homework
problem yet okay yeah so I'm going to
make it a little bit easier okay so in
the homework we are integrating
essentially an exponentially growing
parabolic dish we're finding the volume
under that dish and then we're creating
the flux integral outside of that volume
okay so I'm going to make a slightly
simpler version of this problem where we
have some surface f of x and y equals x
squared plus y squared okay and in x y&z
this just looks like a parabolic dish
okay and what we're going to be doing is
we're gonna find the volume under this
curve so find volume under f of X Y for
x squared plus y squared greater than or
equal to 0 less than or equal to 3 this
is very very very similar to the
homework problem
and so the idea is I draw this kind of
circle here of radius R equals square
root of 3 and I want the volume of
everything under my parabolic dish above
this XY plane inside of this radius root
3 circle okay so what's this weird
looking like cylinder with a paraboloid
cut out of it
that's what I want the volume up I want
the volume of this cylinder with this
paraboloid cut out of it okay now
anytime you see something symmetric you
can probably make the problem a lot
simpler so this is the same as zero less
than or equal to R squared less than or
equal to 3 so I'm gonna use radial
coordinates and I'm going to integrate
this volume using nested cylindrical
shells like Russian nesting dolls okay
how many of you remember doing integrals
with cylindrical shells just adding up
shells of cylinders okay this is one of
my favorite types of integrals that I
still remember how to do okay so we're
going to basically be adding up all of
these cylindrical shells so
okay so we're gonna add up all of these
cylindrical shells where the height of
this shell is given by this paraboloid f
of r equals R squared okay all right so
we have the volume here equals the
volume is some triple integral of DV and
so we're gonna integrate with respect to
radius theta and height this is a triple
integral so I'm going to use cylindrical
coordinates I'm going to integrate from
radius equals zero to root three from
theta equals zero to 2pi and from z
equals 0 to F of R that's just a fancy
way of saying for each radius between
zero and root 3 I'm going to take a
cylindrical shell of height f of r okay
and this is DZ d theta d r okay so
what's the integral of DZ
C okay so I get I'm going slow here
because this is probably the last
example I'm going to do have a real
triple integral so the integral of DZ is
just Z and if I evaluate that at F of R
and then at 0 I just get F of R which is
R squared okay
the thickness of each of these little
cylinder Cassell's is dr okay that's so
the volume is going to be R squared
times two pi times D R okay integral of
theta D theta is just theta so we get
two PI R squared D R okay this is the
formula for cylindrical shells that most
of you wish I had just jumped to write
any cylindrical shell has a volume two
pi times the height which here is radius
squared times D R okay this is just the
formula for a cylindrical shell this is
2 pi H Delta R if you like okay that's
the volume of a very very very thin
silicon cylinder of height H and so
finally I can integrate this with
respect to R and I get R cubed over 3
times 2 pi evaluate it at root 3 and 0
and this is pretty straight forward so
root 3 to the third power is 3 root 3
and I'm dividing by 3 so I get 2 pi root
3 ok so that's the volume of this weird
paraboloid looking thing you could have
just jumped right to here and said okay
I'm going to use cylindrical shells
those cylindrical shells have height F
of R which is R squared and I'm
integrating from R equals 0 to root 3 ok
so this is you know the property a
homework problem is a little bit more
complicated because it's e to the R
squared okay but there is a second part
of this homework and that second part
was to compute the flux through the
surface bounding this volume of a given
vector field that I chose
so let's say that I have a vector field
big F equals 3x minus 2xy in the I
Direction minus y in the J direction
plus 2y Z in the K Direction okay so
this vector field could be the
right-hand side of a differential
equation is it pretty clear how this
could be the right-hand side of a
differential equation right I could have
like X dot y dot Z dot equals 3x minus 2
XY minus y 2y Z like this is a vector
field and it's just a different way of
writing this vector field okay vector
field just means at every point in space
there is a vector pointing in a
direction and so I should be able to
integrate particles through that vector
field using OD YZ like we did in the
first half of this quarter so this is a
vector field and the part of it that
lives in that weird cylinder with a
paraboloid cut out of it I want to know
how much does that vector field carry
particles in or out of that volume okay
I want to know what is the flux of this
vector field through that surface okay
so again we use Gauss's theorem we say
the double integral of my surface of f
dot n DS is equal to the integral of my
volume of div F okay here the divergence
of F is
three minus 2y minus one plus 2y right
partial partial X plus partial partial y
plus partial partial Z my Y's cancel and
I just get 2 so here I'm integrating 2
across my whole volume so what is the
answer then right just two of my volume
right I can pull the constant out and I
just get two of my volume which should
be 4 PI root 3 now it's not always the
case that taking the divergence will
make your life simpler but often times
especially for vector fields that are
interesting from physics like in
gravitation or an electrostatics or in
quantum mechanics fluid mechanics
oftentimes the vector field that you get
from physics your life is a lot simpler
when you try to integrate its divergence
because a lot of times the divergence is
much much simpler than the vector field
itself ok
so there was a Russian guy around the
same time of Gauss that also jointly
invented this his name starts with an O
it's ostrich God Gretzky I can't ever
pronounce its but really we should be
calling this the Gauss rib something
theorem it'd be nice to give him credit
okay that's all I'm gonna do in terms of
examples of the divergence theorem are
there any any questions about anything
that I did so I feel like there might be
a little bit of a mystery surrounding
vector field like we've been doing
ordinary differential equations
that'll makes good sense we know that we
have physics and they have things that
change in time and we want to follow
those things that change in time and we
write down differential equations like
we did there when we move to vector
calculus I don't want us to have any
mystery about what these these vector
fields F mean okay these are just
velocity fields from physics it could be
the field of all vectors pointing into
Earth indicating that Earth's gravity is
pulling us in it could be the vector
field of repulsion between two positive
charges it could be the velocity field
in the Gulf of Mexico that an oil slick
experiences okay these vector fields are
just fields of vectors that I can
integrate stuff through okay they define
differential equations and transport of
quantities in that vector field and what
these integral equations like Gauss's
theorem allow us to do is quantify how
much how many particles will pass
through a certain volume how much mass
will leave or enter a volume in a
physical system so this idea of using
Gauss's divergence theorem for
conservation laws is extremely important
so most of you are going to have some
fundamental physics
equation that you're gonna be dealing
with for the rest of your graduate
career at least this is usually the case
that there is some physical phenomenon
that most people are studying whether
it's an elastic material or a laminate
surface or a charge distribution or some
quantum potential for a laser or a fluid
flow field but there is some governing
equation that determines how that system
is going to behave if you give it
initial conditions and boundary
conditions okay and the whole study next
quarter is going to be about those types
of partial differential equation systems
so continuum surfaces and volumes that
are changing over time and we're gonna
start to see how we might derive these
partial differential equations from
conservation laws today okay
so mass conservation is probably the
simplest example so how many of you know
about this continuity equation that I'm
talking about alright this is the
continuity equation from fluids that the
rate of change of the volume integral of
the mass is equal to the divergence of
the mass out of the volume okay so most
of you have seen it and probably most of
you when you saw it derived it from a
integral formulation most of the time
okay so that's what we're going to be
doing so we're going to consider a
physical volume I'm gonna call it Omega
because V is going to be confusing we
have a volume Omega containing some
fluid let's say we're containing some
mass and that mass is a fluid
okay and we also have velocity field the
arrow okay so this velocity field exists
everywhere that the fluid exists and it
tells me where and what direction how
fast the fluid is moving okay so I have
this volume Omega the boundary is called
partial Omega I always have some normal
vector pointing out of the surface so
surfaces are defined so that they have a
normal sticking out of the surface
and I have some velocity field that
exists in space some of that velocity
field is passing through this volume
okay I have a fluid and I'm zooming in
on some piece of that fluid called Omega
okay and we're gonna say that Rho is the
density okay so any change in the mass
in this volume has to be due to mass
either entering the volume or leaving
the volume right
aside from special relativity there is
no way for mass to be created or
destroyed inside this volume right we've
known this for a long time this is one
of the most abundantly verified facts in
all of physics is that mass is conserved
so any change in mass in omega
pasta correspond to mass either coming
in or out must correspond to mass being
carried in or out by my velocity field V
okay imagine I have a really really
boring velocity field which is just a
river like a river going from left to
right and it's just constant velocity so
what are you saying
that rivers are not boring but let's say
you have a river going from left to
right with constant velocity then the
amount of mass in this imaginary volume
that I've constructed should be
conserved right the amount of mass
coming in from the left is exactly equal
to the amount of mass coming out to the
right because I have a uniform velocity
River okay so that's kind of the
simplest example that should get our
intuition going is if you just have a
constant velocity field then this flux
should be zero right it's gonna be the
same in same out and so we're going to
write this using Gauss's theorem so
we're going to say that any change in
mass is DDT of a volume integral of Rho
D Omega okay so this is rate of change
of mass
okay my volume integral of my density
gives me the total mass the rate of
change of that volume is the rate of
change of my mass and this is equal to
the flux out of the surface of Rho V dot
n D surface so this is the way I just
said it in words this is how we say it
in math the rate of change of mass in my
volume is equal to well it's negative of
the flux of mass out of that volume if
mass leaves my volume I have a negative
rate of change of mass in the volume
makes sense any mass that leaves the
volume means that my total integral of
mass in the volume is getting smaller so
maps out of the volume can only be
carried by a vector field V that has
some component pointing out of the
surface in the normal direction so I
integrate over my surface V dot N and
those contributions carry my mass
density Rho out of the volume okay so
this is the mathematical statement of
conservation of mass in a arbitrary
volume Omega this doesn't just apply to
fluids but you know I have this vector
field V that can carry me out of out of
my volume okay so now what we're going
to do is take this integral and using
Gauss's theorem we're going to turn it
into a volume integral so that we can
kind of relate these two volume
integrals okay so this volume integral
of Rho V dot n is equal to minus the
triple integral over my Omega of Rho
times the divergence of V over my volume
so from here to here we just apply
Gauss's theorem the flux of mass through
my surface is equal to a volume integral
over the entire enclosed volume of the
divergence of my vector field Gauss okay
and so now I can take these two volume
integrals and I can write them kind of
all on one side so this volume is taken
this integral is taken with respect to a
volume and I can bring my D DT inside
that volume integral so I get triple
integral of Omega of D DT Rho plus Rho
div v D Omega equals zero okay so what
did I do here I just took this volume
integral and this volume integral and I
brought this one over to the left hand
side so that this minus this equals zero
and now this is the integral form of
conservation of mass okay this is the
integral form of conservation of mass
and this is a super useful general
formula but what's interesting about
this is I didn't use any special
properties of this volume Omega all I
the only property I used about Omega was
that it was relatively nicely behaved
and smooth it could have been huge it
could have been really really really
teeny it could have been square or
spherical or oblong it doesn't matter I
didn't really specify anything about
Omega so this volume integral of this
quantity has to equal zero for all Omega
this is true for every Omega you can
name practically for every nice smooth
Omega and so the only way that that
could possibly be true is if this
integrand was equal to zero I say that
again this volume integral is equal to
zero over every possible volume you
could draw you could draw that Omega
that I drew there you could draw a
little cube you could draw any Omega and
move it around and this quantity is
still going to equal zero and the only
way that that could possibly be true for
all of those infinitely many volumes is
if this quantity on the inside was equal
to zero and so the only way that this
can possibly be consistent is if D DT of
Rho plus Rho times the divergence of V
equals zero everywhere
okay this is our first partial
differential equation this is a partial
differential equation for mass
conservation this is called the
continuity equation and fluids and
elastics and it's called a partial
differential equation because I'm taking
the derivative of P with respect to t
over here and with respect to space over
here right I have partial X's and
partial Y's and partial Z's so we have a
partial differential equation and this
is a linear PDE because first
derivatives are linear operators so this
is a linear PDE
okay so Gauss's theorem can be extremely
useful these interval theorems and
calculus are not just esoteric they're
not just I you know all the problems
that I'm gonna give you I made up some
vector field that would be easy to solve
but in reality the real use of these
integral theorems is so that we can take
conservation laws conserved quantities
and write them as differential equations
that we can solve on a computer that we
can analyze and start to really think
about how how does fluid move in a river
how does silt move how does nutrients
move how does oil move in an ocean and
you always start with these conservation
laws okay that's where all of like our
physics equations start typically that's
yeah you got a question right so
if I take and integrate my density over
my volume I get my total mass now I
could take that total mass and I could
say what is the rate of change of that
total mass in time and it would be the
same as saying well what's the change of
little mass here little mess here little
mess here and integrating up all of
those local rates of change of mass so
this DDT can go inside this integral
because this integral is not with
respect to T and Rho is not at least
right now like this Omega is not not
changing in time if Omega was changing
in time then I would I would not be able
to do that but for a fixed volume Omega
I can bring this DDT in okay any other
questions about this yes okay if Rho is
not a constant then you're right then
Rho should be I think inside the now I
think actually Rho is outside yeah I
think you got to be right it's gotta be
div dot of Rho V yeah
yeah that makes more sense right good
yeah exactly if it's a constant then it
pops out yeah all right thank you and if
it's a constant then D DT of Rho
probably also won't change and then
you'll just get the divergence of V has
to be equal to zero but that's fluid
mechanics okay so that's everything I
have today I think next time we'll talk
about path integrals contour integrals
and conservative vector fields thank you